let me just put things in perspective
your career earnings ufc i just searched
at seven million dollars is that about
right curry earnings not not
sponsorships outside no no but you i did
a lot more what did ufc pay you uh i did
a lot more the the thing is that people
don't know is we have a show purse yeah
like that way my contract was i had a
show purse at a winning person but i
will also um when i used to fight
back
back in the day i had the percentage of
the pay-per-view buys oh no [ __ ] this
part yeah of course it was part of my
contract
nowadays i think it's it's different
because the ufc's i think give that
right to espn and i don't know for how
long it is so the fighters it's sad
because a lot of them they don't have as
much power so you made more money back
in the days than today i think i think
because of the infrastructure of how it
was made
i think the fighters had more power
before i'm very lucky to be to have been
competing during that era of time
you know conor mcgregor obviously is the
one that i think made the biggest
hearing in the sport and because he
touched the pay-per-views um
i think
i don't i don't have the stats to stick
in front of me but i know like
ronda rousey is there too she was
amazing she made great for for herself
in terms of of of gain of
i think brock lesnar is there could be
but you know what i mean i'm just very
feel very fortunate to have competed
during that era of time if i would have
done it during rice gracie mark coleman
it was terrible they were underpaid like
so bad and if it if it's now now the
problem is they
they have power but they don't have as
much power as we used to have when we
could touch the
a piece of the pie you know what i mean
some fighter does but i don't think they
have as much leverage in negotiation
it's kind of sad yeah do you think like
if you look at what's evolved within the
ufc world
uh the pd's always been a topic of
discussion people will throw under you
know left and right
was it more uh of a topic of discussion
early on the early early days or you
kind of got away with it back at it then
was it more than 2000 was it
it was a topic of discussion all the
time but the the thing is it was so much
in your face that for me it wasn't it
was an insult you know what i mean like
like i i
it's still
there's still a problem we're not gonna
lie there's still a problem there's
still uh you know that
it's it
there's still a there's still a problem
there was always be but it's much better
now now they're testing the fighters but
there are still ways that you can cheat
it's it's it's kind of easy in a way to
cheat in a way you know what i mean
we all have a
card that we fill up that
it's called a whereabout you tell them
where you are and every time you you can
lie on that that we're about to you
chant or you
you can lie and if they show up to test
you they say they're gonna ring you and
say hey we're there to test you where
are you you know what i mean and you you
can you know what i mean you just have
to don't i think it's three two or three
three strike you can't have so you know
what i mean the guys that does uh
use performance enhancing drugs they're
they have ways of of you know the system
also could be corrupted sometime you
know what i mean when there is money
involved there is always corruption a
little bit so it's much better than it
used to be but it's not perfect but it's
much better you know they made they did
a good job
well the concept of fighter pay that's
something we've been discussing pretty
openly we had francis naganu right here
uh you've interviewed dustin poirier
you've we've had uh uh sugar rashad
evans in here we've you've been on rogan
um we've had these discussions on
fighter pay uh you broke down the ebitda
of what ufc is
um but you're saying that fighter pay
today could be better or what are your
thoughts on that oh yeah it could be
better a hundred percent it could be
better it could always be better
we like we are
like i feel um
the baseball player or occupy i know
hockey because i'm from canada
in the days that they were underpaid you
know before they had the the union to
protect them you know it's the same
thing in in fighting
one day there will be a union to protect
fighters it has to be it doesn't doesn't
make sense very interesting concept
right there because there's the you know
nfl pa there's the nba they've got their
union the baseball
why is there no union in the ufc
fighting well everybody want to be in
control and i think it's it's
it's when there's money there's always a
conflict and stuff you know and i i
that's why they asked they have been
some organization that have tried to do
it but they it was conflicting with
others and and that's very unfortunate
but the
the reason of why they want to do it
it's it's great it's a great great
reason you know it's it's a it's not
it's it's a it's a very good good one
i think it will happen one day a hundred
percent and and very often it's funny i
have some of the
some of the parent they come with their
kids they're like hey george this is my
son he's the future world champion of
ufc what advice would you give him i
tell the kid i say
you're doing well at school stay at
school yeah train if you want you know
what i mean train you know do it and if
you but don't put all your eggs in the
same basket thinking that you're gonna
make it because statistically
you're going against the uh big time is
one guy on maybe
a hundred thousand maybe even more you
know and i'm not talking about fighting
i'm talking about basketball okay same
thing same thing fighting is even worse
because get punched in the head you know
like american football very very bad too
so what i said to the kids yeah try to
make it but don't give up school
don't give up school because at least
if you're
30 years old or late 20s and you found
out that you cannot make it for x reason
if you don't have education that you
have nothing that you can fall back into
but if you do have education at least
you have an assurance you know what i
mean it's very important very very
important i i see
in the gym where i train it's one of the
places i love to go because it's it's
very therapeutic for me i love it i love
the science to go train but it's very
sad would you have liked it if somebody
gave you that advice when you were 14.
yes people give me the advice
but do you do do you how did you take it
when you were 14 when somebody said that
to you i took it i i listened i i
stopped school i stopped i was in
university in kinesiology
and i stopped it
when i had my first title shot and i
told my parents because my parents
always
put school in priority they say georgie
not never going to leave school
and and
until you you live through our
supervision you know what i mean we're
always going to push you to school and
as and i thought it was a great you know
but when i had my first title shot at
the time i was working like crazy i had
like two three jobs studying at school
and part time in in the same time and i
wanted to achieve my dream was to become
world champion when i thought matt used
before i thought you might use the first
time a few
few months before i told my parents i
say is it okay if i if i stop this
this session and i go back if things
doesn't turn out i go back next session
because if if i miss this opportunity
it's my dream to accomplish that to
become champion i i i have to train
full-time to put to put all my the
chance of on my side and my parents says
yes
go for it you know and the the reality
is a lot of the people when i go
training in the gym they come to me and
they want to have advice from me they
say george what should i do and
sometimes i'm like oh yeah when you show
your punch i give them technical advice
but the real advice sometimes i should
give them but i cannot do it because
they're gonna think of me being an
arrogant prick i should tell them i say
hey
hey mr x
you're 33 years old
you've been losing your last three
fights
it's sad
i'm sad to to to announce you that
you're not gonna make it you're not
gonna go in ufc and even if you if you
make it
your best years are behind you you know
it's finished you should
keep training but find yourself a real
job you know like like a real goal in
like and it's sad because i will see
their dream
shattered on in their eyes and i don't
want that meet that person that that
that tell them that and it's very sad
because
it's a movie that i've seen many times
is a very very bad ending you're gonna
finish physically broken
and and financially br broken as well
you know what i mean it's very sad it's
we only talk about the people that makes
it but there's a lot a lot more
people that does not make it the odds
are against you
it's
the reason why why i was able to make it
it's it's yeah people say you work hard
i work hard but the stars were aligned i
was lucky and fortunate enough to meet
the right person at the right time the
path would was open for me i made it you
know maybe if one of the of these little
thing changes i would never have made it
you know what i mean you know you don't
know maybe you can have a car accident
and get hit and never be able to compete
or never come back the same i had an acl
tear i remember um
it was about uh 10 years ago i had acl
terror the doctor told me he said you
know georgie fouda if you would have had
the same injury a few years back it
would be a career ending
so sometimes life
is the line is so so tiny you know what
i mean it's one thing influence another
thing and this
you know what i mean that the odds are
against you so
you need to have an assurance education
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]
you